Hey dudette.
Dude.
And dudettes.
Are you gonna like pick that up?
I think they're like really trying to get in contact with you.
Are you like gonna pick that up?
Are you like gonna answer that?
Hey dude.
Hey dudette.
Um actually...
It was me.
I'm the one calling you.
And you need to pick up your phone.
Because it's shredding time.
It's time to get... groovy.
Welcome.
To not Metal Gear Solid 2.
Hey dude.
Hey dudette.
Do you know what day it is today?
Oh yeah.
Everybody salute.
Kosha!
Thanks for the 50k.
Thank you for the 50 gift.
Thank you!
It's April 30th my dude!
It's April 30th!
The most important day!
Yeah!
On this day!
My favorite couple in the world!
Shoutouts to you Jack and Rose!
They've met!
And then they went home and watched King Kong!
And history!
Was made!
So we're like gonna...
Celebrate that.
Hey man, did you know George Washington took office as the first president of the United States of America over 200 years ago today?
Today we're now the United Wisps of YouTubers!
Let's see.
So if you were unaware...
The...
Metal Gear Solid 2...
Substance...
Has a special little...
Extra...
Thing we got going on here.
If you could see at the very bottom.
Here's to you best boy and worst girl.
She's not the worst girl, come on.
Snakeboarding.
If you will.
Yes.
Snakeboarding.
So we'll be happier April 30th.
Happy April 30th!
Bluey Emmerich.
So worst.
The forgotten sibling of the Emmerichs.
What's wrong with BB?
B-B.
Skateboarding?
That's a thing?
Oh yeah.
It's only for...
Um...
It's only for MGS2 Substance.
So...
Um...
If you give it like the Master Collection...
Or anything like that.
It's not gonna be on there.
You gotta get...
MGS2 Substance for the PS2 baby.
I got my PS2 set up right over there.
I got my Retro Tink 4K all hooked up.
I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
To skateboard!
Um...
Honestly...
I can't say how long today's stream is gonna be because...
We could...
Um...
I think there's like not that much to do with this.
But um...
Yeah I...
I dropped some...
Okay.
Because I like was planning on doing a bunch of like...
You know...
Um...
PS2 games and stuff like that.
I kinda dropped the money on it.
So...
It's for your viewing pleasure everybody.
It's for your viewing pleasure.
You're welcome.
Oh thank you for the super chats you guys!
Um...
I totally thought about doing like a marathon.
For this stream.
You know...
Playing up...
Playing up to...
You know...
The game...
Or...
Like playing...
Marathoning the game or something.
But um...
Honestly...
I thought...
I kinda wanna save MGS2 again for when I properly replay the series.
So...
I didn't wanna replay it and have it on my channel and...
Or play it and have it on my channel and then replay it again.
Like...
Sometime...
Uh...
Down the line.
I don't know when.
So...
Instead I was like...
Well what else can I do for April 30th?
And I was like...
Wait a second...
I know the coolest thing we could do.
Dude?
So...
Without further ado...
Oh...
Sorry...
You'll see the...
Everything kinda loading.
Feels so...
It feels so...
Old school, right?
Oh my gosh.
Game, are you okay?
Oh there we go.
Oh...
Yeah!
Raiden...
To disarm the terrorists...
You must...
Shred on Arsenal gear.
Raiden...
To save America...
Do...
Your...
Best...
And...
Ollie...
I don't know.
Welcome everybody to MGS2!
Let's see...
Controller...
We got Ollie...
Small jump...
Hold the button to crouch and release to jump.
That's the X button.
Simple enough, dude.
We got this, dude.
We can grind...
Rail slide...
Jump on a rail, etc.
And hold down the triangle button to grind.
Oh...
Yeah...
Raiden...
Flips and grabs are done in mid-air.
A series of tricks can be done until you reach the ground.
Got it, dude.
Oh...
We need those six...
Six flips, boss.
I got you.
Can't wait for Raiden to activate roller blade mode.
Raiden...
Do spins by turning while in mid-air.
Okay.
L2 and R2 are spin.
We got...
Grab is circle.
Flip is square.
Umm...
I probably won't remember any of these.
Take a dupe on your board.
No!
Don't do that.
Don't dupe on the board.
Duping is uncool on the board.
Good morning, Mint.
Good morning.
A little pause... and we are back.
Oh my gosh, no way.
Hold on, let me go back real quick.
Okay, ollie, grind...
Flip and grab.
Flip, grab.
Grind, grind.
Ollie, ollie, ollie, ollie.
Time for a stream.
Also, I finally saved up the last five dollars I owned... I owned the Canadian Mafia stuff.
These DMV photos...
They don't even look like them.
Like, what are these models?
They look so strange.
Who should we start as?
Should we start as Raiden because it's his big day?
Or should we start as Snake and finish with Raiden because it's Raiden's big day, everybody?
No, that is not solid.
Snake Skateboard.
Snake first?
Alright.
Now loading.
Okay, here we go, baby.
Alright, ollie, grind.
Oh, I don't remember which one's flip and which one's grab.
Alright.
Mission information.
Snake.
Score 8,000 points.
Find the hidden item.
Grind 150 meters.
Collect four dog tags.
Destroy all three uninhabited probes.
Blow up the plant.
Squares flip.
Okay, thank you.
Here we go.
Oh, yeah.
Oh!
No, it's so awesome.
Oh my god, we're grinding first.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, I got caught.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no.
And we're gonna grab.
Just did a flip.
Just kidding.
Oh.
We did a kickflip.
Nice, Snake.
How many points do I have to...
Oh.
That was a big fall.
Are you okay, Snake?
Oh, I have to get on top of those.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, nice, nice.
Good job, Snake.
Good job.
Nice.
Did we grind for 100...
How many meters was it?
How do I take this thing out?
Oh my god, it's shooting at me.
Kickflip.
All you did was...
Snake, all you did was jump.
Ha!
Oh!
Oh my god!
How do I get the things up there?
Maybe here.
Ha!
Nice!
A cipher.
How do I get the things up there, though?
And there's an item over here.
Oh.
Oh, Snake, are you okay?
Oh my god.
Power slide.
How do I get it over there?
Is that the hidden item?
Wait, I think I can go down here too, though, can't I?
Oh, sorry.
He's so thick, he bounced.
Oh my god, there's so much down here.
Oh, nice, nice, nice!
Wow!
Nice!
Good job, Snake.
You didn't crash.
You didn't crash and die this time.
Okay.
Thank you, Joshua!
I can't read it right now.
We have 24 seconds, you guys.
I don't think we're gonna make it.
Nice!
Good job, Snake.
Okay, we'll come back for that.
Oh.
What?
Oh my god!
What kind of murder was that?
A D!
No way!
We didn't get a single man.
It's okay.
Oh my...
Those scream while falling feels anticlimactic.
I like the way he kinda like, flails his arms a little bit.
Did you guys hear that?
His little...
Oh
gosh...
Oh gosh...
Um...
Do I have to do it?
Wait, how fast do I have to go?
No way!
Body burial.
Body...
Okay.
Oh, it's still alive!
Uh oh.
Nice.
50-50 grind.
Nice!
Oh, it's still alive.
Oh, ouch!
Oh god, we're bleeding!
Blue...
British wisp catching a streamer once.
Not a bot.
Thank you!
Sorry, I do plan on doing more, um... Come on, Snake.
More EU-friendly streams.
Oh, that's a bird.
Okay, Snake, we need to get you up here.
Oh!
Nice.
I should be more careful.
My bad.
Okay, let's go up here.
Here we go.
Nice!
Wow, this is actually huge.
Do a kickflip.
Kickflip!
He listens so well!
Oh!
Uh oh.
That should have been easy.
Three out of four?
Nice.
Where's the last one, I wonder?
Um...
How do I grab?
Huh!
Oh, I stuck it!
I stuck it!
Oh!
Na na na!
Uh, let's go back downstairs, I guess.
Oh.
Nice.
There's some stuff over here.
Snake!
Ah!
Yeah, let's make the sound effect ourselves when we die, right?
Okay, but how the heck?
Show us some tricks!
Come on!
Okay, we completed one mission!
We just gotta keep going!
Ha!
Nose!
Okay, snake.
Grab it!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Yo, yo, we got so many!
Ah!
Woo!
Oh!
Okay, come on!
8000, please!
8000!
Come on!
Kickflip!
Come
on!
Please, please, please!
No!
Oh!
We were so close!
Oh my gosh!
If only I had landed it!
Neo, thank you so much for the 20 gift!
And thank you!
Did you know that the engine that drives this was made for the Konami skateboarding game, Evolution Skateboarding?
Which also has some big shell base levels as well as Castlevania.
I did know about that!
I didn't know about the Castlevania though, actually.
Hidden...
Grind...
Wait, we still haven't done the full grind?
Oh dang!
Look at me go!
Oh my god!
Hey there, dudette!
Could I get a totally tubular happy birthday on this raddest anniversary of our nation's and my birth?
Get a channel!
You have a pretty awesome birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Happy April 30th!
The day of George Washington and of Gaia Channel.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
I mean, have a radical birthday, bro.
Do you remember what day it is on April 30th?
Yeah, it's the day my dude Snake did a 1080 double ollie and grind.
Dude is bodaciously radical and righteous.
Rose,
what are you doing?
Oh my gosh!
Oh, I stuck that.
That was so crazy.
We got all four dog tags.
I wanna blow up the plant!
Okay, that's gonna be our goal right now, is figuring out how to blow up the plant.
I wanna cause violence.
Oh, is it that over there?
No, hold on.
Oh, Snake, turn around.
Look!
Snake, you're doing awesome.
Oh!
Ah!
What a shame, indeed.
Choose violence.
Let's go downstairs.
See if we can find how to blow up.
Wait, can you stop for a second, Snake?
So I can look around.
Maybe over there.
Oh, sorry.
Uh-oh.
Was that what I think it was?
Oh, wow!
Oh my god, we made it.
Oh my god, we made it!
Oh!
Huh!
Um...
Wow!
Oh god.
Oh!
Uh-oh, Snake, get out of here!
Snake, get out!
Snake?
There we go.
No, no, no!
Snake?
Okay, this way.
Never mind!
Why?
Okay.
50-50.
Oh, I see it's a total of 150.
Okay, okay.
I don't know why I thought I had done it.
Oh my god.
Snake, you have to jump up high enough!
Ducky, thank you!
Ooh!
Ghostacular Shredder.
Oh god, no, no, we need to...
Come on, Snake!
I wonder if there's a way to get more time.
There's not much point in being here if you don't do any tricks.
Shut up, narrator!
Okay, Snake, jump!
Jump!
Don't do it!
I'm just trying to turn around.
I'm just...
There we go.
Check the other side.
Okay, yeah, let's try this side.
Oh, wait, we need this...
Wait.
Oh, you're...
I think we need this part.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, hold on.
Snake, turn around.
Turn around, Snake!
Snake!
Ouch.
Oh my god!
Snake!
Looking good, he said.
Oh, interesting.
It's okay, we were dead anyway.
Okay, so once we get that...
How do I still have a D?
Okay, then we have to go get the other ones.
Looking good.
I'm a disaster, yeah.
Disaster side.
Look at that!
That's so sick!
Look at him go!
Don't look at that.
Don't look at that part.
What's the difference between retry and replay?
I wonder.
You're killing it, dude.
Go!
Uh
oh, I don't think I killed him.
I don't think I killed him.
Oh,
it shows the video of what I did.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Oh my god!
I made it!
How did I make it?
Snake, don't...
Okay, Snake.
I need you to just turn around, buddy.
Very slowly.
There you go.
Okay.
Yeah!
No, please!
Please!
Snake, turn around.
We need some... we need some...
Oh wait, let's go to this one real quick.
Whoa!
We made it!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Where are those?
Oh, Snake.
Oh my god.
He gets a little...
He gets a little out of control, you know?
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah!
Woo!
Oh
my god!
You guys, I'm killing it.
Nice.
Oh.
Almost had it.
Okay.
I think it's on this side.
Let's go and destroy our side out gear!
Woo!
Okay, now where the other one is.
I don't know.
Uh...
Wait, now that's a door.
Keep going.
Upstairs, maybe?
You think it's upstairs, maybe?
Is this David Hayter VA-ing?
I wish.
Shut up!
I'm going!
Ah!
Oh, there it is.
He
dead?
Wait.
Wait!
Where is that?
Oh, got a dog tag.
Ah!
Oh, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Come on, Snake.
Get back up.
Oh my god, no, no.
Don't get me again.
Ah!
Mission completed.
Okay.
Let's do a little celebratory grab.
Or that.
Whatever the hell that was.
Um...
Ah!
Oh my god!
Are you okay, Snake?
He's fine, he's fine.
I wonder if the hidden is like, get all the birds or something.
You know, something crazy like that.
Ah!
Nice!
Oh!
We almost had it.
Still a D!
Ah!
This makes me want to see you play the original Tony Hawk's game in Tony Hawk's Underground.
You should be more careful.
Ugh!
That's so awesome!
That sound is so great.
Wait, hold on.
I want to see it next.
If we do replay, let's see.
Oh yeah, you're right!
Slow...
Oh yeah!
Oh my god!
Whoa!
How do I go fast?
Oh.
Wait, no, no, no!
Back, back, back, back!
Oh, I went...
Yeah!
And then...
Slow...
Oh, no!
Snake!
And then I stood there trying to turn around.
Frame advanced.
Oh wow!
We can get like frame perfect shots!
Yeah!
I should not have made that.
I think he's a pro.
Oh!
It's okay.
He lived.
And then he...
It's okay!
He's...
It's the...
It's me trying to do the set up.
It's killing me.
L1 is slow, right?
It doesn't feel very slow.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
We went crazy there.
Oh god.
Yeah!
Oh, and then I fell off.
That's okay.
I'm surprised they didn't include Fatman on his rollerblades for this.
Right!
It would have been perfect.
Oh, I'm crying.
I'm crying from laughing so much.
It only has been a half hour.
This game is kind of cruel though.
They give you...
Oh, I clicked restart!
Oh, no.
They...
They only give you like so few times...
so few minutes.
Thank you, Dive!
Could you perhaps may chance be untubular?
Absolutely not.
I am the most tubular ghost man you'll ever meet.
There's one thing.
You'll find out when you see a man grinding on a skateboard on the connecting half pipe to Shell 2.
I've seen someone use that box trick before.
We'll lay a trap on Shell 2 connecting half pipe.
There he goes.
Okay, retry.
How many...
How much time do we have?
Three minutes?
Yeah.
Bod-varian.
Oh, no, Snake.
Jump.
No, Skryde.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Dang it.
We got it though.
Nice.
How do we get the ones up there?
What?
I want...
Oh, sorry, Snake.
I also want the stuff back there.
Okay.
Go, Snake.
Go.
Hula!
Impossible!
We make the impossible possible.
I have a feeling that the...
that the birds have something to do with the hidden one.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Not today.
Cypher!
Ouch!
Why are you still shooting me?
This is good, isn't it?
Can you imagine what Big Boss would think?
Oh, yeah.
Let's go.
Let's go blow up.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Okay.
Hup!
Oh, nice!
Oh.
Snake.
Jump.
There we go.
Yeah!
Big Boss would be like, that's my son.
Oh.
No!
I was not aligned.
It's okay.
50-50 grind.
This remix is awesome.
Oh.
What the?
What's going on?
My son.
Oh.
No!
Snake.
Nose grind.
Grind mission completed!
Awesome.
Hup!
Okay.
Here's the true mission.
The true challenge.
Ah!
We only have 30 seconds, Snake.
We gotta get destroyin'.
I'm trying!
I'm trying, sir!
Please.
Hup!
Snake!
Yes.
Nice!
Okay.
Let's go get the first one.
Come on, Snake.
Come on.
We got this.
Right here.
Right here!
Don't try too hard.
Oh!
Oh no!
We don't have the time!
Go, Snake!
Go!
I don't think we're gonna make it.
We're not gonna make it.
Don't try too hard.
We only got one in the end.
Actually, it says there's four...
It says there's four...
Four...
Ciphers, but...
But I only saw three.
Three!
We gotta go find the last one.
Retry.
Let's go try... Let's go find the last one.
Hmm... A board to surpass Metal Gear.
We
didn't...
We didn't take him out, but that's... Okay!
This way.
Oh my god.
How am I supposed to do this?
No way.
Wait.
Do I go, like, from up here?
Oh, we made it.
We lived.
Okay.
Okay,
hold on.
We need some...
Oh.
We need some air.
We need some... Here we go.
Here we go.
Okay.
From here.
And... Jump!
Snake, why don't you jump?
Why don't you jump, Snake?
Why?
There's not much point being here if you don't do any tricks.
Jump!
I think it's jump and release...
I think the release... Okay.
Like, I think it's...
Okay, like this?
Jump!
Cha-ching!
Okay.
I get it now.
So it's... You hold...
I get it.
Here we go.
Come on, Snake.
Ha!
Cha-ching!
Okay, now that's...
What am I supposed to do there?
Wait.
Do I... Can I grind and jump at the same time?
It's like that in Tony Hawk 2.
Okay.
Jump off.
Oh, wait.
Oh,
so close.
You're so close.
Good jump.
No!
How am I supposed to jump?
Oh my gosh.
We're gonna get this.
This will... This is what we'll practice.
Okay.
Here we go.
I'm holding... I'm holding... Jump!
Grind on the handrail instead?
There's no way I should keep getting a D.
Okay, let's go back to that spot.
Let's go back to that spot.
Yeah.
Okay.
Huh?
I pressed...
I pressed the wrong line.
Ha.
I think... I think I get the timing.
Maybe... Oh my god.
Alright, here we go.
Turn around.
Go!
This is so... tricky!
It's okay.
Snake... Snake, you... you got this.
You got this, buddy.
Okay.
Fine, what are you doing?
Hold on.
Okay, hold on.
Too early might be better than too late.
Yeah.
Hold on.
Okay.
Okay, if I'm grinding... grind, grind, grind on there.
Okay, okay.
I'm shredding, I'm shredding, I'm shredding, I'm shredding, I'm shredding.
We got this!
Dude!
I was a little off on my calculations.
Okay.
We have a whole minute to learn this.
Oh!
This guy is getting on my nerves.
How is it so funny every time?
It's the way he like flails his arm, you know?
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Why?
When I'm off, sometimes he catches it.
Other times, he doesn't catch it.
Okay.
Here we go.
Please, show us some tricks.
Please.
Please do something.
Okay.
Down.
Ah!
What?
Okay.
You guys.
I...
I was holding X the whole time.
Okay.
That one, I was not holding X.
Ugh.
But did you release X?
No.
I did!
You can't see my hands.
Actually, you can see my hands.
But my hands are shredding right now.
I'm focused on my own grind.
Okay?
Okay.
Are you playing through OBS?
Oh.
Oopsie.
Ta-ting!
I... I basically... That was like a hoop, though.
Come on.
Eh?
What is that?
How do you land that?
Come on, Snake.
All you did was jump!
Oh my God.
Okay.
Bomb rush cyberpunk.
I don't
even see what it was!
What was the hidden?
Where's the...
I'm trapped here.
Oh.
I'm trapped here, you guys.
Uh-oh.
No, Snake.
Turn around.
Turn around, Snake.
No!
That's a disappointment.
What was the thing?
Hang on.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh.
Come on, Snake.
We need you to catch some...
I did not press X soon enough.
That was mean.
It's all mean.
It's okay, though.
We got it one time.
We can get it again.
This is it.
What?!
I held X.
You gave...
Fifty-five!
No, please!
Please, I held X and I let go!
This is so messed up!
This is so messed up, Snake!
Okay, come on.
Why I'm not grinding on the rails outside?
Instead of jumping?
Because you have to...
Because they cut off.
You have to do it.
Oh, unless you mean like...
Okay, I think I...
So like controlling it to go to the...
Okay.
I think I know what you mean.
I think I know...
Hold on, let me see.
I think...
I think I get what you're saying.
I think I'm catching what you're putting down.
I think I'm...
Understanding the gravity of the situation.
Okay.
I think I got it.
I think I know what you mean.
I'm gonna try it.
No guarantees.
Like so here...
And then...
Oh, I won't let...
Unless it's like pitch perfect.
I don't know about that one.
Yeah...
What's over here too?
Alright, snake.
But slowly.
Slowly.
Slowly, snake.
Don't...
You don't wanna die here.
Snake.
Looking good.
Why can't I...
Why can't I grab it?
Good?
Um...
What?
Okay, I think it's bugged maybe.
Nice.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh!
We got this guy.
Do
I have a health?
I wonder.
Oh.
We almost made it.
No, no, snake.
Snake, don't die!
Phantom coin.
Okay.
Oh!
Almost.
Oh.
No, I...
I...
I don't think it read the image.
I don't think it's a good input.
Happy Big Shell Day!
Happy!
Whoa!
Big Shell Day, everybody!
Yeah!
Yaaaay!
Wow!
Yes!
Adio!
After all of that?
Still, we get the big D.
A hind D!
Let's check out Raiden's.
Endgame.
That was a good run, though.
Good run, everybody.
Wait.
Oh, wait!
Oh, I just realized my bad.
I thought... I don't know what I thought.
Sorry, my PS2 is going kind of crazy.
My D is ready for the X Games.
Hope you're having a totally gnarly April 30th and enjoying the FGS skateboarding.
The full game is playable Grilukovic soldiers, Simon Belmont, Frogger the Frog, and boss battles against enemies like Dracula.
Plus, it's fun having snakes skate in Tokyo.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
Splitstream Sim.
Looking pretty rad, boss.
Thanks.
This is how George Washington always wanted us to commemorate today.
Don't you agree?
This is actually how we crossed the Delaware River.
I didn't know if you knew that.
I didn't.
I didn't know that.
That guy.
Mr. Washington.
I hope you're watching.
This is what you fought for.
This is what makes us free.
The right to skate!
Wherever we please!
It would have been so cool if I had blown up the...
Okay, let's try it.
I wonder if there's a blow up one for Raiden too.
So this is Route B.
So I guess it's different.
Prognosticateur.
Mint has to nerf herself through OBS because she would be too good.
I finally figured out how to do it though.
Operate the crane.
Collect four rations.
Wait, is there less stuff for Raiden than there is for Snake?
Where am I crazy?
8,000 points.
Rhyme 150.
Look at his...
Sir?
What are you doing to the skateboard, huh?
Yeah, there's no dog tags.
Yeah, yeah.
Hands on the...
Sir?
Raiden?
Oh, he's serving.
Look at him.
Rations instead of dog tags.
Okay.
Go!
I see a ration right over here.
I keep...
Oh.
Whoa, look it.
There's a whole place here for us to grind.
Tail slide.
There it is.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Dang it.
I don't think I destroyed it though.
Ow!
Oh god, Raiden, your head.
Are you okay?
Oh, you almost had it.
You should be more careful.
It's time for Jack to let it kick.
You guys like that?
Rrrr.
Raiden, Raiden.
Rules of Skater.
Thank you for the Hakketsu.
Oh my god, please.
Um, we'll just ignore that for now, okay?
Just kidding.
Justice.
Has been served.
Nice!
It's okay.
We at least took him out.
Nice!
Doctor, turn off my skate inhibitors.
It's time for Jack to let her rip.
Come on, Burge.
Oh, it almost had that skating here.
I realized.
Nice!
Almost had the body burial, but we at least killed the thing.
Keep going, keep going.
Oh, so close.
So close.
Oh, oh, oh.
I thought I was about to die.
Huh!
Yeah!
That's the way, baby!
How do I destroy?
Maybe down.
Oh!
Huh!
Whoa!
We made that!
No way!
I like destroying the boxes, too.
Oh, yo!
Yo!
We did that, guys.
This is the crane, obviously.
Hmm...
We gotta figure out...
Ah!
We try, we try, we try.
Go!
Let's do this first.
50-50, Burge.
I can never make it.
Oh my god.
Come on, come on, Ryland.
Nice!
Oh!
I can never get the body burial.
Scary.
What's scary?
Did they want to say kawaii?
Kawaii and kowaii are different.
Of course they wanted to say kawaii instead of kowaii, you know what I'm saying?
Oh, no!
Impossible!
That was a big fall!
Nice.
Even though I didn't get it.
Wait, is the hidden spot in the same place?
No way.
That was sweet!
Oh, no, no, no.
No, no!
Oh, dang it.
Nice.
Took that guy out.
Nice!
I'm starting to get sweaty.
I'm shredding too much, dude.
I'm just... Okay, here we go.
Oh, no!
I almost had it!
I forgot.
Okay.
It's not a disappointment.
My mom says I'm not a disappointment.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, no!
I jumped too early.
Denver!
Welcome to
Nembu ship!
We got this.
Please!
Please, I don't have much time!
Please, game!
No, please, Watashi!
Raiden!
Stop going through.
Okay.
Please, Watashi, make it!
Ha!
Not the hidden.
Huh?
That wasn't the hidden?
Uh-oh.
Baited for real.
Okay.
Let's try and find the way to activate the crane.
Um, I also want to find...
I only know where two rations are?
Nice.
You're so radical, MaidmentVTuber.
Thank you.
Thanks.
I know.
I like...
I like who I am.
Getting some sick air.
Is this even possible?
I don't know.
Let's go upstairs.
Oh, come on.
Raiden, you have to push.
Oh, is this it?
Oh!
There's the hidden!
One out of Oh!
That's a disappointment.
Nice.
Keep it going.
It's right there, isn't it?
Oh, I have to go downstairs and do it!
Okay.
Erg.
Oh, there's the other ration.
Oh, we made it!
Let's go.
Wait.
What does Circle do again?
I can't remember what's the difference between Circle and...
Square.
One of them's grab, one of them's something.
How do you use your special?
I have no idea.
Circle is grab.
Circle is grab tricks.
Okay, okay, okay.
I tried maybe, like, grabbing the side of it.
It didn't really work.
No, Raiden!
No!
Actually, that works.
Nice.
What?
Is this what happened on April 30th?
You know it.
And that's how we get the hidden!
Come on.
Get out of here.
Just leave.
Oh.
Just go.
Just go, Raiden.
I wanna get more than a D.
I wanna get...
A C!
So close.
No ration, please.
I wanna get a C!
Yes!
That might be it.
That might be a C.
That might be a C, you guys.
Can we get any more?
Wow!
Are you kidding me?
Are you, like, squitting me right now?
Is it just D or...
D or no D?
You know?
You have to get the D?
Or else...
Or else?
Is a C in my heart?
F.
No, it's a D!
Don't make it any lower!
Because I'm not doing enough side tricks.
Oh, sorry.
Sick tricks.
Actually, though...
Raiden.
Oh, Raiden.
We gotta grind.
We gotta score.
Crash?
What's the crash?
Wait, what is...
Oh, the probes.
Look at the membership!
Thank you!
Score's too low.
So maybe it doesn't have anything to do with the missions.
Maybe it's all...
Maybe it's more to do with the...
There it is.
Our actual score.
What if I just grind the whole time?
There we go.
Nice!
Special R1.
Can get you a lot of points.
R1 is our special!
Oh!
Oh, nice, nice, nice!
Okay.
Also, I keep forgetting about...
This!
We can flip in the air!
Keep forgetting!
Smooth!
So we have to go upstairs first, right?
So far, so good.
Ish.
Come on, Raiden.
Oh.
I keep forgetting about L2 and R2.
Oops.
We did something there.
Oh no!
Raiden!
Go back!
Minty's a real skater, not a poser.
Obviously.
See?
Only a real skater would have landed that.
Nice!
Okay,
let's go back downstairs.
Oh, Raiden, Raiden!
Wait, turn around.
Oh wait!
Actually...
Yeah, I wanted to do that.
Maybe I'm not hitting enough of the...
Or landing enough...
Nice!
I destroy the things, but I don't land the trick.
You know?
Come on.
Let's go.
And...
Nice!
Why does this game even have skateboarding?
Why wouldn't it?
Because MGS2...
Is the greatest...
Of all time!
I'm grinding up the stairs.
Go, go, go.
Come on, Raiden.
Oh my god.
Please.
That was close.
Okay.
Now we gotta get this ration.
Wait.
Does L2...
Maybe L2...
And R2 don't do anything.
I'm trying!
Oh my god.
Wait.
No, please.
Oh.
What did I say, though?
What was the jump button again?
It's X.
That was...
You guys!
We did it!
We got the C!
I actually feel like I was doing pretty well until the end there.
Oh my gosh.
If I had collected...
If I had gotten that...
And then the score.
Oh my gosh!
Random well-being checkup.
How have you been, Big Mint?
Here's $50-y news.
Get yourself some bread, mate.
Maybe some banh mi, too.
Thank you!
I'm good.
Thank you so much.
I mean, I'm totally tubular.
I just got a C.
And you know what?
C means degree.
Yeah!
C's get degrees.
That's the saying.
C's be degrees Celsius.
Oh man.
Yeah!
Absolutely!
C means cool.
I like the blowing.
I actually think Snake's map was harder.
I think it was more difficult.
But maybe that means we can actually...
um...
complete all the missions on this one.
Who knows?
Oh, no!
No!
Come on.
Come on, Raiden.
Get it together, buddy.
So close.
Oh, C, C, C!
Oh, wait.
I did go the right way.
I thought it was going wrong.
Okay.
That's fine too.
Raiden, please.
Raiden.
To take care of the terrorists.
You must grind.
Oh, damn.
We didn't...
He's gonna...
Yeah!
All according to plan.
Obviously.
Nice!
Oh, no!
I was so close.
You know what?
We got the money.
We got the cash money.
It's fine.
Let's get out of here.
Let's go blow...
Not blow it.
Let's go do a crane.
Kickflip!
Give us some extra points.
While we're...
Oh.
Come on, Raiden.
Okay.
You know what?
This works too.
We gotta get the...
We gotta get our grind on.
Ouch.
I missed that a little bit.
No, that is not a solid snake.
That's sick!
Snake!
Yeah!
Looks like...
Out of seven uniques.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Impossible!
Did we land it though?
Did we land it?
Did we land the impossible?
That's so close!
Raiden, Raiden, please turn around.
Raiden, I can't see you.
Okay.
They don't call it the impossible for nothing.
It's mostly for him.
It's for his ego, you know?
They call it the impossible, but it's like the easiest trick ever.
Wouldn't that just make him feel really bad?
April 30th, my dudes!
April 30th!
George Washington!
Oh.
Take it.
There's not much point in being here if you don't play tricks.
Um...
This one was not my best run, I'll be honest.
No.
What an end.
Truly.
La li lu le lo.
It's a la li lu le lo.
They're...
They're trying to stop me.
The la li lu le lo!
Oh, damn.
I was so close.
Please, Bryden.
Just get a bit of...
Disaster.
That's mean.
That's what they call me at the club!
Disaster.
Disaster slide.
La li lu.
La li lu le lo.
What's up here?
I haven't been here.
Oh.
I can't see that hole.
Ha!
Oh, dang it.
Uh-oh.
We're in trouble.
Ah!
Don't shoot!
What club?
What
club?
Nice.
Oh, so close.
I also want to get these up here.
He was shooting at me and I was...
Yeah!
He was shooting at me, but I was too busy being awesome!
Yeah, the club.
Obviously.
Please, Bryden.
Let's go upstairs.
Take the stairs now, Bryden.
Here we go!
I take... I phased into the box.
I'm gonna take Cypher down with a skateboard.
Yeah.
Yeah, I do.
Cypher's got nothing on me.
Well, this...
Those Cyphers...
And...
And this Cypher...
Wait.
Those... Wait.
Cypher and these Cyphers.
Okay.
That's alright, Bryden.
So, pick it up.
Pick it up.
No.
Wrong way.
There we go.
Up the stairs.
One of my mortal enemies that I can't ever...
get to the stairs.
Warned you about those stairs, bro.
Yeah!
Oh.
Sorry, Bryden.
Why can't I get this?
But it's so hard for me to get this ration.
Oh my god.
What?
Why'd you stop, Bryden?
Why'd you stop?
In the end...
Everything is bad.
I did one.
I just did it.
Come on.
Ration!
Oh.
We didn't get the grind, either.
I think getting the grind is like...
Going...
There and back.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
Like this?
Nice.
Oh.
Why did you...
Why did you fall?
So close.
It's okay though.
Now we go around this way.
And we waste all this time.
And we hook!
We're going so slow!
Oh my god.
Ride in, don't do it.
Don't ride in!
We gotta grind everything we see!
Like we're a bunny or something.
Badass.
Where's all the bird poop?
That's a good question.
I took care of those birds.
Nice.
Oh.
For some reason I keep thinking I gotta go back here.
But I don't.
Not yet.
Not here yet.
Like you're a what?
What do you mean?
Oh!
Let's just pretend we're on the same lap.
I
didn't want those points!
Anyway!
Ride in.
I need you to... I need you to... you know... my money's on you.
My money's on you.
I need you to...
Ride in.
I'm gonna go broke.
Don't you care about me.
Oh!
We got the grind at least.
Ride in.
Lock in.
You know what?
Let's just do this part.
Oh I don't think we're gonna make it!
I don't think we're gonna make it!
I miss him in the game would just tell you, You're bad.
Ride in.
That's a disappointment.
Stop making me so sad!
Ride in.
You're making Mike sad.
Oh.
Sorry.
I just realized.
I hate this
guy, I think.
Oh my gosh, maybe...
No!
How do I get that one up there?
C though!
We got the C!
If I had just gotten that at the last second, maybe it would have been a B.
Jump?
I've tried!
You know what?
We're gonna go practice that one right now.
We're gonna go straight to it and practice.
This way.
And if I... jump!
Well, that obviously didn't work.
Hold X and release at the edge of the ramp.
No need to hold forward.
Izar!
Izar my man!
That was all you, buddy!
There we go.
Nice so...
Could not see.
Alright.
Let's...
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh...
We wasted a little bit of time, but... It's OK.
Let's just beat these cyphers.
Woo!
That hurt.
Oh, Raiden?
Raiden, all we did was... all we did was turn around.
All we did was turn around, man.
Oh.
Wait, which one's kickflip?
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Kickflip.
It's a kick.
And then it's a flip.
Oh,
wait.
Raiden.
Oh, Raiden.
Raiden, Raiden.
OMG,
is this real?
You bet your butt it's real.
What was that?
Oh, Raiden.
Come on.
Let's go, Raiden.
What's stock one mean?
Oh, didn't someone say...
I can do like a special trick or something.
Does that mean my special is stocked up?
Huh.
Oh.
Wait.
That's my special meter.
R1!
Does nothing!
I got another stock!
But how do I use it?
Hmm.
Nice.
How do I use it?
Hmm.
Oh, I was gonna say, wait, I got the collection.
No, we didn't at the beginning.
Okay.
I think this time, for real, we can get the collection.
We can get a beef or...
Bud?
Ballad?
Bake?
Burn?
Then I think we'll be good.
Bows?
Huh!
Wah!
Oh, dang it!
Oh no!
No, no, no!
Oh gosh!
Oh!
Yippee!
B for box.
B for...
BJ!
Wait, no, no, no, never mind.
I was thinking D for DJ, but...
No!
I didn't mean that!
You
guys know D for DJ, right?
Woah!
Okay.
I think I'm normal again.
Yes.
No.
You don't seem to have enough guts to do any tricks.
Yes, sir.
Disaster slide!
No, sir.
Oh.
It's Raiden, please!
We only have a minute, Raiden!
There we go.
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
I cannot stop saying that.
I think there's something wrong with my brain.
I can't just stop saying yes, sir.
No, sir.
Yes, sir.
Oh gosh.
Oh no!
Actually, this is okay.
To thank you!
Yeah!
Oh my god, wait, you guys.
I just need the score!
No, no, no, no, please!
Raiden, Raiden, don't do this to me!
So close!
Oh, so close!
Oh my gosh!
No, not B for BJ!
No!
Not B!
But we got the B!
B, B, B, B!
We got the B!
You're making progress!
Yeah, baby!
Yes, sir.
It takes a well-balanced individual to grind the rails.
B for ghost boos.
Boo, boo, boo!
Yeah!
Boo!
Oh, I'm sweating so much.
Do you guys mind if I go get some more water?
Here, you can watch the replay.
While I go get more water.
I'll be right back.
Here, I'll even get rid of this.
B, R, B.
B, R, B!
Wait a second.
I just joined the stream for the BJ.
No!
Wait, I might need to go change.
Why
is my dress all wrinkly?
I
think I sat weird and it's all wrinkly.
Oh, no.
Wait, I'm gonna go change.
I'll be right back.
Okay, again.
B, R, B, part two.
I'm so sorry.
B, R, B, part two!
Hold on.
I'm gonna restart it for those who missed it.
Right?
Restart.
There we go.
Okay.
All right, B, R, B.
I have T-minus three minutes.
Into my shirt.
Okay, I'm so sorry, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, okay, okay.
Exit.
All right.
I changed into my hungry for snake T-shirt.
I realized I don't have any MGS2 T-shirts.
I have only MGS3.
I have MGS4, MGS3, Peace Walker.
I didn't buy the one from Uniqlo because I didn't like it.
The blue on it is so blue.
It's so blue.
Like it's way too blue.
I'll never...
I'll never wear it.
I do have one that says Solidus on it.
Maybe I should have worn that instead.
Oh, the fat man!
My laughing gross.
Alright, guys.
Today's stream is actually going to be pretty short.
How did you know I had that t-shirt?
Actually, it's not a t-shirt.
But, you know.
How did you know I had a shirt that said that?
It happened real fast.
It's because I love Fat Man so much, you know?
Min, do you know what day it is today?
April 30th?
It's shredding day!
Every MGS fan has it.
Oh, okay, okay.
But, I believe this is the round where we'll get an A.
For that ass!
Let's go!
Let's grind!
All the way!
To...
Dinner, baby!
Oh, ouch!
That was not what I expected.
Wait, why are you facing this way?
Okay, we're close, we're close.
April 30th!
So right.
Why didn't I think of that?
You should be the streamer.
Not me!
Oh!
Ew!
Ew, ew, the camera.
It's okay.
It should be you on this livestream!
Not me!
Nice!
Why do you not land the kickflips right in?
You're killing me!
You're tearing me apart!
Right in!
Oh!
That was...
That was so wet!
Please, Raiden.
Hold on, I'm coming back over here to get...
Oh, never mind.
You know what?
Screw it.
Sending Gray Fox?
It's like when you play as Gray Fox in VR missions.
I did!
Raiden's bloody skin mark.
What do you mean by that?
Oh, my gosh.
I don't think this is the run, you guys.
Um...
Uh-oh.
I don't know if this is the run, but we'll try.
Oh, wrong way.
Oh, my gosh.
This is...
We'll try.
Oh...
Okay.
Come on.
Oh, whoa.
Alright, we'll go back up the stairs.
I held on, but it...
Uh...
But we haven't even gotten that one.
Yo, this is not the run at all.
That's okay.
Good job, Raiden.
Nice.
Turn around, Raiden.
Ouchy ouch.
That's okay!
That we didn't make it.
That's okay.
We didn't get the grind, either.
Yeah.
We're getting consistencies, though.
Not so bad.
Okay.
Here we go.
How
do I use my special?
Oh, if only I hadn't crashed, we would've made that.
Ooh.
This one's fancy.
Nice.
Okay.
There we go.
Speedrun.
Nice.
Okay.
Kickflip.
Kickflip, my beloved.
Kickflip,
my beloved.
Kickflip, my beloved.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
We still need to grind, though.
Come on.
Raiden.
I know.
I'm trying.
Mister, please.
Okay.
When we go back down, we'll get that.
Probably.
Jump!
Oh!
Okay.
Turn around.
Jump!
Yeah!
Okay.
Let's go get these over here.
Still have to make a lot of points, though.
Tail slide!
Oh!
Okay, that got us a lot.
Nice.
Let's just do it again.
Yes!
No!
Oh!
That works.
That works!
Ha!
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no.
Please.
We did it!
Let's go!
Oh my god!
Oh!
April 30th!
Oh my gosh...
You guys...
It is time...
to do the final part of April 30th.
While we watch...
my awesome run.
While we watch my awesome run.
Punch Solidus?
No, not yet.
I love that guy.
Hold on one second.
Here we go.
Okay.
Well guys, thank you very much for joining me for...
for this super awesome, super cool, super sick...
time today.
I hope that you had an awesome April 30th.
And remember...
that the Patriots will never win.
It was time to watch King Kong.
No.
It's time for our final...
our final part.
Actually, I'm gonna restart this.
Restart.
There we go.
Okay.
I will sing to you...
a song.
I stare at the stars and the sky up above and think what am I made of Am I full of...
Am I full of sorrow?
Am I hurt and pain?
Or am I filled with love?
I walk by myself on the streets below And ask every child I know Do you think tomorrow I'll nail that kickflip?
Which one, which trick will go?
I can't say goodbye to yesterday, my friend I keep holding on Till the end Out of the darkness There is no other way Than the light leading to yesterday
It's there That I'll find Inner peace Please, not more than dreams that I let slip away.
Joan, please!
I will find the ration I'm looking for way back in yesterday.
I
forgot my saxophone.
This is cinnamon.
Why
can't each of us in the world ever see the best things in life are free?
Why can't each of us in the world ever see the best things in life are free?
Little sounds of laughter, a warm hug, a smile, a kickflip from you to me.
I fall to my knees, I cry and I cry.
Why couldn't I just fly?
Oh, my scapegoat!
Happy ever after.
Please stay for a while.
Make time refuse to fly.
I can't say goodbye to yesterday, my friend.
Cause I know how good it has been.
Facing forever, here I stand, come what may.
In the old and the new, yesterday.
It's there that I'll find inner peace, not war.
And boards that I let slip away.
I will find the joyfulness I'm looking for today.
April 30th.
Whoa.
Here it comes.
Oh!
Come on.
Whop.
Wholololol.
This is a trumpet.
This is not a saxophone.
The saxities.
Thank you, guys, again.
That's a trombone?
Trombone?
Oh.
That's a trombone, but we don't have a...
Hold on, I'm gonna skate with him.
I'm gonna skate with him.
Oh.
Yeah!
Wow!
Here I go!
Yeah!
Oh.
Here we go, here we go.
Oh, I tried.
Yeah!
Kickflip!
Keep going!
Keep going riding!
Yes!
I can't say goodbye to yesterday, my friend.
Oh.
We're okay, we're okay.
Wow!
Uh...
That's it.
That's the stream.
Thank you guys.
Again.
I hope you had fun.
Um...
Happy April 30th.
From me to you.
And um...
So gnarly.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you guys.
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Actually, I will be collabing with Giri on her channel.
Um...
I don't...
Actually, I think I can stream tomorrow.
I don't know.
I think I'll stream tomorrow, probably.
Gonna tell you now you are not beating the cute allegations.
What is that?
What do you mean?
I'm not cool?
I mean cute?
I'm cool!
Wow!
Yeah!
Here we go.
Wow!
Yeah!
Nevermind.
It's fine.
I was gonna take that but I didn't.
Okay.
130th Happy Metal Gear Day!
Again, I'll probably stream tomorrow.
I don't know what yet.
I'll put up a waiting room...
tomorrow morning probably after the GD collab.
So, yeah.
Thank you everybody!
I know it's silly but this stream has been the coolest thing.
And the song just wow.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Isn't it so awesome we also got the A?
I'll try and get an A on Snake's map too.
But I think I'm way better now than I was before.
I think I can do it.
Also, oh my gosh, you guys!
Close to 200k.
I have to think of something to do for 200k!
Uh oh.
Almost 4k.
4k left!
Wait, oh, it doesn't say...
What does it say actually?
Yeah!
4k left!
Oh my gosh.
Hahaha.
Eat 200k calorie mix.
Eat 200k calories!
Got it!
I'm gonna eat 200k calories.
Perfect.
No elation 200 times.
You would want that, wouldn't you?
Okie dokie.
I'll think of something.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for subscribing.
Thanks for being me.
Okie dokie.
See ya.
See ya bye.
Y'all stay safe out there.
Y'all be good out there.
Bye bye now.
Bye bye.
Endurance karaoke to 200k when?
I don't know.
I mean, I have karaoke on Saturday.
I'm trying to rest my throat a little bit.
So...
Bye bye now.
Bye bye.
We'll see.
I don't know about karaoke.
Bye bye now.
Bye bye.
April 30th!
Yippee!
Lalilulelo.